Linting is a way to automatically check
your Java script code for errors.
And it can be done at various stages
during development via your editor,
your build process or
your pre-commit hook in version control.
There's not always a right or
wrong way in linting.
A lot of it is heavily opinionated.
So you should choose the configuration
that fits your coding style and project.
There's also the difference of code
style linting versus syntax or
structural linting.
Syntax or
structural linting is what most people
refer to when they say linting.
These rules check for
JavaScript anti-patterns, such as
unreachable statements or forgetting
to do a strict comparison against null.
On the other hand, code style linting
can complain about things such as
variables that aren't
properly camel cased, or
a particular way of placing braces for
a function.
So if linting ensures your code looks
sexy and checks for all these potential
errors, does that mean your code will
always run if the linter is happy?
Nope.
The linter only checks for
potential errors.
It doesn't actually have any idea
what you're trying to accomplish.
So now that you're familiar with the
concept of linting, let's talk solutions.
There are three popular JavaScript
linters out there that developers use,
JSHint, JSCS, and ESLint.
You'll find a link in the notes
that details the differences, but
to cut it short, we'll stick with
ESLint as it supports modern ES6 code,
can be extended, and has output
that's really easy to understand.